so today we're going to look at
security protocols and it turns out that
it's actually
not that easy
and there can be interesting ways in
which to attack them
a while ago i was talking about rsa
which is a well-known example of public
key cryptography public key cryptography
also known as asymmetric
cryptography is a little bit
like having a little padlock we have two
parts we have the public key and we have
the private key and we generate those
together that's what we saw in the rsa
video and then the idea is that we can
use
the public key
to lock something which i'm going to
have an analogy we're going to lock this
envelope
now the envelope is locked now of course
for a physical envelope you can just
tear it or open it another way but we're
going to you know keep the analogy so
nobody can open this lock except for one
person which is the person who created
the look who has the private key this
little key here um so the owner of that
can now open the message using their key
by opening the lock
and taking it out
right but in order to do the encryption
because this is private
cryptography
you could have done this yourself you
don't need my key to lock the message
you only need my key to unlock the
message
so if i for instance
write a secret on here is this what
we're saying
yep
you haven't seen
and then i put it into the envelope
and then
you know the point is that i can lock
this without
having the key right
that's right
so i don't need the key to lock it it's
locked
and then i can hand it back to you
right so you just send me a message
which nobody else can read but me
because the only way to read it is to
open this little lock and there's only
one key in the world that can open it
and i've never given this key to anyone
else so i can now open
the envelope
[Applause]
and
read your message
and it all works exactly as intended
right you can use this to send a secret
message to me but now the problem is how
do we know that the person that has a
key is actually the person that we want
to talk to so let's say that you want to
know
who i am right i claim
that i am bob
but you want me to prove this to you
so what we can do is we can use the same
trick you obtain my public key because
it's public anyone can get
the public key belonging to bulb
right and you do exactly what you did
before you come up with a secret you
encrypt it with that
you put it in the envelope and i'm the
only one that can open it so at that
stage i've just opened it just like
before i read your message
and all i do
is give you back
the message
and you read it and you're like right
this guy must have this key otherwise he
wouldn't have been able to read the
message so i'm using the fact that i can
read the message as evidence to you
that i
am bob i am the holder of this
private key
and we did it here over the table but in
reality you might want to do it over
post right and this is the design
challenge of the internet so it's a term
that many of you will have heard of in
some way or another it's called a man in
the middle if i send you a message over
the internet
um it isn't just going to pass through
my computer and your computer it will
actually pass through various servers
all around the world routers network
devices
and so we do we don't trust them they
can potentially read our messages
um and and try to play around with that
and in this analogy that rule will be
taken by the post right you're going to
post the envelope to me and i'm going to
receive it by post okay so we have our
post box here i'm going to put my same
secret in there
i'm going to lock it
with your public key
once i've done that i'm going to pop
that in the post box
and then at some point or another pet
the postman
will be emptying
the mailbox
the letterbox and
he'll get access to the locked
letter
and if they're doing their job well
they'll deliver it to me
and i will open the letter
so i know the secret is 42
and i'll give the secret back
to the mail
and then
the postman will deliver the left
so let's pretend
that pat the postman is malicious
they're trying to pretend that they are
mean they're trying to pretend to be
bob so they want to convince
you ellis
that they have possession of this key
and thereby being able to pretend
there's someone they're not
so if you post this letter this is back
to where we were with my secret in a
letter with you lot with your public yep
gone back in the post yeah and we just
established that there's only one person
that can open the letter and it is the
person with this key so if pat the
postman is able to open this letter for
you you would be convinced that they
have this key correct
okay so you just gave the letter to pat
and challenged him to open the letter
but what pat does is he doesn't try to
open the letter he just gives the letter
to me
and i'm like oh okay i'm challenged to
open a letter
so i open it
and say to pat
you see i can open it there you go
and
next step is pet delivers the letter
back to you
ah so as far as i'm concerned pat's just
given me that number correct so that
means pat must have had possession of
this key from your point of view
so you're now convinced that pat is bob
patenble by the same person
which is obviously not the case right so
pat has now successfully broken this
very simple protocol now this sort of
attack is known has been known for a
long time
and of course all the protocols are are
a lot smarter than that but these are
the challenging
things that you need to face when
designing a protocol you can't make
these simple assumptions that just
because someone is able to decrypt
something it means that they must have
the key no they might be able to use
tricks so you want to design your
protocol to make sure that these tricks
do not exist the protocol that we're
going to be looking at is the needham
schroeder public key protocol
because it's a public key protocol the
very first step is that everyone
involved generates a public key and a
private key so as before
we have my private key and my public key
i give my public key to everyone else
and similarly you have a private key and
a public key
and you give your public key to me
now the goal of that protocol
is for us to exchange secrets
so that we're both convinced that we're
talking to each other
and we know each other's secrets now
knowing each other's secrets is useful
because we can then use that as a later
basis to come up with a so-called
symmetric key
that's typically how it's done
and we need to be wary of pat the
postman playing around so in the needham
schrader protocol
the first step will be that alice will
create a secret like before
but also she will write down her
identity on a piece of paper now this
will make sure that if i bob receive the
closed envelope i will know not only the
secret but also the person that was
challenging me to open the envelope
which in this case is alice so please
write down your identity on a piece of
paper
alice and i have my secret from before
which i'm going to reuse
envelope
and i'll put in
my secrets
and my name
and then i use
bob's public key
to lock the envelope
because i don't need the key i can just
push it shut
and then am i sending this file the post
then you are yes okay so we've been
posting that
okay and then uh yeah thank you pat for
delivering
alice's message
i see an envelope here i wonder who that
could be
and i'm able to open it because it was
encrypted with
my public key
[Applause]
there we go
let me have a look
ah we have a secret number
and we have
the name of the person who's challenging
me
alice so now i know
that alice is trying to talk to me and
that she came up with the secret 42.
now to prove that i have
this key i need to prove that i know the
number 42 so i'm going to send you back
the number 42 this is to prove that i
was able to read the message
and i'm going to write down a secret of
myself
i'm going to pick a number which is easy
to write read upside down
and i'm going to
put this in an envelope
and in order to make sure that pep the
postman can't pretend to be someone
they're not
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
lock it using your public key alice's
public key
do you not put your name on it what is
that
i am not putting my name on it that's a
good observation that it will actually
turn out to be very important
and i'm putting this back
to patrick the postman
and giving it back to you okay
so
i'm opening it up
got my post let's put my camera down
again
and
i've got my private key
with my a on it so i am going to unlock
it
so i have
and 69.
so
i think i'm satisfied that my
messages got to you and come back again
yeah so you know that it must have
gotten eventually to the person holding
this key and you now also have the
number 69 so that means that you
not only know that it was me that must
have read it at some point you also know
the pair of the secret numbers 42 and 69
and so do i
but i don't know yet
that i'm talking to you so you need to
now prove that you are who you say you
are
by showing that you were able to open
your lock now what would be the solution
for that i guess i'll send you your
number back you just send me my number
back that's exactly right
so can you you you can use my public key
for that
okay so
do you need anything else in here or
just interesting
okay so
69 goes in there
and it gets
locked with
your public key
and post it in the post box
and sent to you
thank you very much
let's have a look
whether the person who claimed to be
alice in the beginning is actually alice
or not
69 they must be great so now we're both
convinced that we have been talking to
each other so you know you've been
talking to bob i know i've been talking
to alice we both know the secret number
69 and 42 and nobody else in the world
knows that combination of numbers these
are very rare numbers that you almost
never find
and what we can do is we can for example
create a so-called symmetric key out of
these two numbers of course these
numbers in computers would be way larger
and you can use that to to do crypto
more efficiently and we can communicate
to each other more quickly using this
new key we don't have to fiddle around
with these public keys anymore
because just as it was a little bit
clumsy for us it's also a little bit
clumsy for computers to use
um asymmetric encryption okay so that's
all great um but what i said is that
these protocols are often
not as secure as you might think now the
interesting thing was that there was
actually a proof that this protocol was
secure and it kind of is
because if you're planning to talk to me
and i'm planning to talk to you
and we do this whole setup
there's no possibility for patrick
postman to interfere there's nothing he
could have done
to make us miscommunicate and use
different numbers or find out what the
numbers is or confuse who we're talking
to
but there are some scenarios that were
not considered back then
where actually there is an attack so if
we rewind all the way to the beginning
and like before instead of talking to me
you want to talk to pat the postman
okay so what would you do if you wanted
to talk to pat the postman
uh i'd send him
a secret on my name you would send him a
secret and your name and you would close
the envelope with what with his public
key with his public key why would i want
to talk to pat
well
in the case of the postal office there
might not really be a scenario but if
you think about the internet there could
be a scenario like that for example
let's say that you go to a
dodgy website right now your computer
will still want to set up a secure
connection to that dodgy website so you
want to talk to the doji website
but then the doji website could like pat
use that connection
to
set up a fake connection
behind the scenes so if you're surfing
to a 3g website this attack could apply
fortunately of course
modern protocols do not have this
problem so it's
okay for you to go to dodgy websites
don't sue me right so you're sending
your secret
and your identity to pat
into my envelope and then we're using
pats
public key
in the post box
and you are now expecting a reply from
pat so what you're expecting pat to do
is to open the message with their public
key
so i'm just going to pretend to be pep
for a second
just to
make this work right so we're using pets
private key to open
the lock
so pat has opened the message that was
addressed to them
and pat reads
that alice
wants to
share the secret 42 and set up a
connection with them right so their job
is to now come up with a secret of their
own
but instead of doing that what pep does
is they actually put
this back into a box
alice and 42
close the envelope
and look it with bulbs public key
and then delivers the letter
to bob
okay so from bob's perspective they just
got a request and they're just opening
it
they don't know at this stage whether it
came from pat or from ellis they just
know that they got a message
and then
i bob
is reading this and says oh
alice
wants to talk to me and their secret is
42.
okay fair enough
and i do my part of the protocol
i take 42 to prove to alice that i am
who i say i am and i create my own
number as 69
and i'm putting them in the envelope
and giving it back
two pads so i'm using
alice's
key here
to lock the message
so because you know it's going to alice
you lock it with alice's key exactly
it's just the name that i found on this
piece of paper here and i'm giving this
back to pets
now at this stage you're expecting a
response from pat and that response is
two random numbers the random number
that you gave to pat which is 42 to
prove that pat has access to their
public key
and another random number which is
generated by pets right
unlock this because that's my private
key there we go
open up the public key
and then here i'll find
[Music]
my 42 that i sent and then a private
number 69 okay so that means that the
person you were talking to is well that
must be
from pat who i sent it to right that's
right because they just prove to you
that they know it's 42. but what is your
response to pat
because pat also doesn't know whether
they're talking to you
i need to send back
the
new number 69
not my secret
and then i need to lock it with pets
public key
and then put that back in
the post right yep so then pat receives
the message
addressed
to pat
so pets will use their private key to
open it
and they can see
your response
which is
so now pat knows both the secrets 69 and
but it's not done yet because pat also
wants to lure
me into believing that pat is alice
right that was the whole
point
so basically the protocol between alice
and pat has now finished and alice and
pep know that they're talking to each
other and there's no problem with that
part of it
but in the very final thing that happens
is that pat
encrypts the message with bob's public
key
okay so we have the message encrypted
with bob's key and pat gives this
message to bob to me and i'm using my
private key
to open it
i open a message
and i see
my own secret being sent back to me
now clearly that must mean that i was
talking to alice because from my
perspective i got alice in 42 and then i
sent a message back to alice with 42 and
my secret 69 and then only the person
that had the key was able to decrypt
that and send it back to me so i must
have been talking to alice
and so i believe that i'm talking to
alice but i'm really talking to pat you
believe you're talking to pat and that
is correct
but that means that
if
pets is a dodgy website and i am
an online bank and you're a customer
right you'd be logging into
a doji website and then the doji website
is using that connection to pretend to
be alice
for that connection so they can then do
all kinds of bad things and i will
believe that it is not pet the malicious
postman but alice my customer who is
doing those things
and that is of course very bad the
reason why this was overlooked for for
over a decade was because it's quite
subtle because you wouldn't expect
initially that alice would want to talk
to pat so it was really
focused on the possibility of just alice
wanting to talk to bob and bob wanting
to talk to alice can anything go wrong
then the answer was no so everyone was
happy but then it turned out that this
scenario exists and that's bad
now is there an easy way to fix this
uh yeah i mean i think i stumbled upon
it actually earlier you should really
have some your name back yes all i
needed to do was in the stage
um
in the stage where i was sending
42 and 69
if i had added another message
saying bob
at my stage
and just put that together with the two
values
in the
envelope and sent it back
with alice's
public key
then i give this back to pat
now pat isn't able to open this message
all they did was forward this message
to you and then you opened it and you
saw 42 and 69 now if you open the
envelope what would you see
oh this is key
now we know
that bob sent this
from the thing i sent to him
and here's a new secret yes because you
would be like hold on a second i was
trying to talk to pat not to bob why
does he say bob and you'd know that
something was amiss and you'd abort the
protocol
and
the attack would fail
now this is academic and this this
attack has been known now for decades
but unfortunately attacks like it
are likely to exist occasionally
because it's really really difficult to
think about all the ways in which you
can combine
protocols and protocol runs together and
the attacker only needs to find one way
to break it and the protocol is broken
and if you're on the defensive side and
you want to make sure that your protocol
is secure you need to think about all
the possible ways in which the protocols
can be overlapping or interfering with
each other and you have to show that
it's always going to be safe and that's
the difficulty
more in front of it
so the belief
would be updated to say that i'm
probably here i take it here
44 and i raise it to the 29th power so i
multiply it with itself 29 times
on the clock and the number i end up
with